well just one more thing to do and i
suppose you all know what it is
let's get down to business
[Music]
we need to talk about mulan more
specifically we need to talk about
what's happening with the release of
mulan and then
we need to talk about the possible
implications and fallout of this now
some of the points that i'm going to be
saying are going to be somewhat
reiterative uh points that i made uh not
too long after
trolls world tour came out because it's
basically a continuation of that
so quick reminder trolls world tour was
released by universal
and it went video on demand
and did quite well of it but then when
universal started
very in a very loose lips fashion saying
well maybe we'll uh we'll do more stuff
like this and won't put as many movies
in theaters
well theater chains got very uppity
about that and then battle line started
getting drawn and the thing is
disney was on the side of the theater
chains
disney was siding with them in most of
this now like i don't want to make it
sound like disney is a big
champion of theater chains disney takes
super advantage
of theater chains and theater owners
it's companies like disney that's why
they these places are profitable on
their concessions
not on their movie tickets because with
the big tentpole movies like star wars
or the big marvel movies
disney has very strict demands
of these places they demand a higher
percentage
of the box office take they demand that
their stuff gets put in the
highest seating capacity theaters that
it has
oftentimes they have a minimum number of
weeks that they have to run in those
largest theaters
but all that being said disney does
want theaters to remain open that's very
much part of its
business model that especially because
disney has been kicking
butt theatrically like some studios
you know like universal honestly
they can have it really mixed from time
to time and you can see why maybe they'd
start looking at a more blended release
schedule or maybe just
start looking more at a video on demand
in general disney though they make a lot
of money on their theatrical releases
and they want to be able to keep doing
that
but mulan
has now kind of changed the playing
field a little bit
so mulan was originally supposed to come
out
back in march i think it was then moved
to an
august date and now it has been
announced
it will be released uh
video on demand for disney plus now
you have to already have a disney plus
subscription it's only going to be
available to
through that service and you don't just
get to watch it because you have the
subscription you are going to have to
pay 30 bucks
for the privilege of watching it if that
sounds like a lot that basically
it depends on whether or not you've got
a kid because
you know at your average movie theater
30 bucks parent kid tickets
in done but that doesn't cover
concessions it doesn't cover popcorn you
know nothing like that
but if you're a family heck if you're
if you're a single parent with two kids
say nothing of something like a family
of four
then 30 bucks is actually a really good
deal for you
so i don't doubt that this is going to
probably
do pretty well for disney um but
you could tell they didn't want it to
come to this
i think pretty much everybody involved
was
really crossing their fingers
that this pandemic was going to clear up
and theaters were not only going to
reopen they were going to go back to
normal
and and have that happen by now and
disney's far from the only one being
impacted by this
tenet um christopher nolan's latest
keeps getting pushed back
they're still they're still claiming
they were that there will be a
theatrical release but
with something as big as mulan was
expected to be
and that you know you could make the
argument that trolls world tour
was had the potential to be more of a
sleeper hit
it wasn't looking to be a blockbuster it
did well and it probably would have done
well in theaters but
it wasn't going to be looking to be one
of the biggest films of the year
mulan was so for them to take that off
the theatrical schedule
that's a big deal so the question
people might be wondering is if disney
wants theaters to remain in business and
healthy
why are they doing this why don't they
keep waiting well
because they can't sit on this stuff
forever
for a number of reasons the first
is they're missing significant chunks of
expected revenue that were planned to
have for this year
and while they can maybe push some of
that back
they need some of it to to move forward
to generate something this year not to
mention the fact that
you know a lot of these studios are
starting to look into restarting
production again
but they've also got a whole slate of
movies that have been pushed back
which means that instead of doing the
normal thing of like
they start shooting something in the
letter ladder end of this year to be
released either next year or early
uh in 2022 they're looking out to like
2023
even for things that aren't big massive
special effects things that require the
extra time just because they've already
got a full slate that they just keep
pushing back and back and back and back
and back
at a certain point you got to start
releasing some of those things if only
because
you make it pointless that you're making
new stuff because you're sitting on
existing stuff
i'm not shocked actually that disney has
said
you know because one of the immediate
questions was you're going to do this
for black widow 2 because that was
supposed to have been out by now that
was supposed to be
may i think and disney and marvel have
gone no
we do not plan to do that for black
widow right now we plan to release that
theatrically probably 2021
so that like i said they did not want
to do this you can tell everything about
this
disney did not want to do but it
eventually it's what
made the most sense or rather it didn't
make sense anymore to not
do it now as far as theater chains go
this is rough this is really bad
because
if fewer major temples come to theaters
especially as they are trying to
start looking to reopen or if more
things get
you know released video on demand in a
shorter window
or things like that which that is pretty
much gonna happen so like amc worked out
a deal with universal
that gave some concessions to universal
in terms of
how quickly after the theatrical release
could something go
available digitally and
amc had to make some concessions to what
universal wanted because amc and amc is
not the only theater chain but they're
one of the biggest along with regal
and they are they had to give up
some stuff because they are not in a
strong bargaining position right now
officially movie theaters are supposed
to start reopening again
at the end towards the end of this month
um august
we'll see what that happens if it
happens it's probably not going to be
across the board
it's not going to be suddenly all
theaters across the country are going to
be open
and there's always the possibility that
they get shut down again
most of them even if they reopen they're
not going to be allowed to fill to
capacity
they're going to have all these new um
procedures that they're going to have to
put in place to sanitize
the space after each screening
all of which is going to involve extra
money and
am and this isn't even speculation on my
part recently
there is word coming down from amc that
they are probably going to extend
the additional cost of the things they
have to do
in terms of sanitization and cleanliness
they're probably going to pass that on
to the consumer
which from a balanced book
perspective i get but and
like depending on how dire their
financial situation they may have no
choice
but to do that but it
really is not a good idea and if they
can avoid doing that they should
because we're looking at look some
people are going to just be like
movies yeah but the thing is
a lot of people are either gonna be
still be scared of this thing
so the idea of inviting them out to
gather around a whole bunch of strangers
in a public place that's already a dicey
proposition
you're asking them to come out and you
know to an experience that
we've gone some months without which
brings up the possibility that maybe
some people are starting to wonder
do i really miss it that much and you're
gonna start
charging them more for the privilege
of this whole thing
i again they may have to
there may be no choice but to do that
but
that's a bad look you know thank you
thank you for coming back and supporting
us and and helping us through this tough
time
give us more money ticks are not 20
bucks a pop
you know it
it's it's it's not an nba pool and
enviable
enviable position for them to be in
and the other thing that people need to
remember because some folks might be
wondering well
us is hardly the only market and while
the us may be
in not great shape when it comes to
handling this thing
there are plenty of other markets that
are doing better and their theaters are
opening
well yeah but you need to remember
by and large these domestic companies
you know universal paramount disney
warner brothers they get a bigger cut of
the box office
domestically sometimes some of these
distributors
have to partner with somebody else when
they do overseas
you know whether it be china or europe
or anywhere else and so they're losing
part of a cut to that they may not have
as good a deal worked out with theater
owners in other countries
studios make notably less
uh off of the international i mean
like the raw numbers are very good but
like they're cut
the amount that actually goes to the
studio is a lot less
a lot of these studios really depend on
the us market
for their bottom line not just for the
wrong number but for
being more profitable business because
they take a larger percentage
in the us market the vast majority of
them do with mulan
going video on demand the question is
whether this is going to open the
floodgates
because there is the distinct
possibility if this goes well
which to be honest we may not know
because
streaming numbers don't have to be
reported it's not like um tv ratings
which because
you know they're being broadcast on
public airways
um you know we we find that information
out
streaming service numbers they don't we
only know what they are if these
streaming services tell us and they
generally don't unless they're like
insanely high numbers
other than that they talk in vague
platitudes oh well it did very well for
us
but if it appears to do well or
good if it does well enough that disney
is actually willing to brag about the
actual numbers
that could open the floodgates for
pretty much everybody else to go a
similar route
now i would say the only other
service that's really in a position to
do it exactly the way that
disney's doing it with mulan is warner
brothers because they've got hbo max
they have a
fairly sizable platform to get it done
on
most of the others they either don't
have
their own platform or if they do it
doesn't have anywhere near the market
penetration
of disney plus or even hbo max
so it's hard to know
how far this will ripple out but this is
potentially the start
of a massive shift not necessarily
because
anybody wants theaters to die but
because
studios can't sit on these things
forever and this pandemic is dragging
on and it's going to continue to
hate to be the bearer of bad news on
that but that's the reality
i i'm honest i am really worried about
my local movie theater
i'm lucky enough to live in a town that
has a local theater as opposed to
something that's part of a massive chain
because i don't like the big chains
i like my rinky dink little local
theater
and i'm worried about it because i know
the big chains are
struggling right now and there's an open
question as to how much longer they can
hold out
without reopening and even when they
reopen if they're not able to fill to
capacity will that be enough to keep
them going
i think we may be looking at a forced
paradigm shift that
it may not i wouldn't expect to see the
elimination
of theater going but it
it's gonna it's gonna impact it in some
way
i would not be surprised if a fair
number of theaters close and the
emphasis
on the theatrical release gets dialed
back
we'll see this bums me out more than it
probably has much right to but i really
enjoy going to the theater
i like taking my kid to the theater it's
something
that i don't want to see get swallowed
up by this
show that's going on but
may still be what happens you know with
everything going on maybe um
maybe it's time we give up on movies and
got back in the books
said the aspiring author yeah as if i
didn't have a dog in that race too
um that's actually a very clumsy segue
to
a another creator that i want to
highlight because since this video does
not have a sponsor
i want to highlight another creator on
this platform in this particular case
it is a channel called the artisan geek
which the reason i have that awkward
segue is
it's a booktube channel where she
talks about and reviews books
classics new books she'll do videos
around a theme
she has a great presentation style i
really enjoy
listening to her talk if books are your
bag
too she's a good booktuber and worth
checking out and i do definitely
recommend her again that is the artisan
geek so mulan
going video on demand what are your
thoughts on that whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it you know all the
stuff to do i have a
patreon which is uh what is keeping uh
me in this house right now uh and
in addition to that there is all the
usual stuff like share subscribe
bell so on all of which help me in
at least a little bit in some way so any
or
all of it i deeply appreciate but
you also don't have to do anything
because end of the day
you're the council i just run the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]